go to this video with 15 minute game
against chess fawn how Norway let's see
em now we'll get a king's indian or
modern defense let's see what is doing
don't back to a king's indian ok yeah
played a lot of the h3 line maybe go for
something else okay night a six we don't
get the absolute main line which I for
once I would have tried but not a six is
a completely different animal not the
typical race situation looking you one
there there is something like that would
be one playing it very positionally
rookie one Bishop everyone at least them
I'm not getting mated with this
automatic attack here that's very
comforting 927 wow
hmm not quite sure what this is doing is
he preparing d5 really normally the
night is on a six because well after a
five at some point right very often will
move the deep on and then the night gets
a new square on c5 you don't really put
it on c7 if not really provoked to do so
then it's hard to provoke that even
night basically never goes to c7 but ok
maybe it's got some some funny idea with
it well D Phi they have a five and I
don't think that this isn't blacks
interest to do now maybe you really be
fire then we're going to play be five
you know I can play the move a4 it's not
terrible a form probably that a five and
the night all the way back to before
yeah not so not clear I can also always
answer b5 with c5 it's not not bad as
well but ok here be 5c 5 DC DC we would
try it Queens which it's not really good
for me I have more space I don't want to
trade Queens on behalf of course I can
just take that's also an option it's not
bad actually let's do that b5 takes
takes be form yeah that's that's quite
good actually making the night on c7
look a bit stupid and b5 takes takes be
form after that I have the idea to play
d 5 94 96 this route be one is designed
to prepare this before
okay should be seven hmm not quite clear
he wants maybe take with the knight on
d5 yeah maybe Bishop e3 would be a quite
okay with 94 is a bit a bit annoying
okay I'll take this temple play h3
Bishop e3 it's maybe a bit slow but I
still like my position
he played that really okay it's better
than then with just see cb5 because the
night would have been really bad unknown
1c7 okay so before you before night XD
40 text if I Bishop f5 I have Bishop d3
so that's not a problem actually d5 pie
I can play d 5 now I don't have
sufficient control over you for Saudi 5
is ready a month one that set sir that's
not good
maybe I'm a three maybe I should have
played the 45 myself and set up a three
yeah d5l d5 is a problem 'if I've always
thinking along completely different
lines of this limb okay now i can play
d5
and I have have a good controller now
over this Queen to Queen moves Bishop
deform and it looks like I'm enjoying
some space advantage with no big
drawbacks 924 is a bit tricky i mean i'm
hanging eufaula they want to control the
whole sea far like the C 3 square
Wow
killing the g7 bishop okay but it's it
can it has a role on age 16 okay if I
take here I can take I can take all
these six maybe this ship takes and it's
not clear what I'm gaining I can take a
five it's not particularly great the
real problem is that Bishop e3 am i'm
hanging e-form and Knight c3 I don't
really have a good square to go to I can
go to to be too but then bishop age six
is really a really annoying and okay
going to a 7 s not changing anything no
I probably must do that I don't don't
really see in other ones dropping it
back to a 1 or B 2 is just like nothing
and what about this position black can
pin play Bishop c4 maybe sorry bit of a
sore throat him takes can take before
I mean okay I'm threatening to take on a
five so probably black should take on
before not sure I can take a check with
the rook it's not it's not bad okay
played evil yeah I'm not guessing many
moose yep but this is not this does not
mean that he's playing a badly eb-5 Iago
beef i bestow be five is still a
weakness here I would have tried motor
to to trade down on the queenside but he
didn't didn't go for that at all night
okay if I go queen-to-be to this this
should be quite okay right attacking on
f6 move like night h5 is just not not
very attractive can play that but it's
not great can take play 94
take 94 94 Bishop c4 yeah even that is
not not totally totally clear and maybe
I can take on c4 i put the night via e 2
2 C 3 okay what I was getting at is
Bishop c4 Bishop takes e4 takes and then
nitey to to c3 getting it to a nice
blockading square and then concentrate
on the weaknesses d6 and a form yeah
that's actually quite good I'm
threatening to take on c8 know where to
take on b5 this is probably he must play
Bishop c4 I really don't I really don't
see a big alternative here Bishop c4
looks looks normal and then I take on c4
edge once the pawn nope well he's not
playing any of the moves I absolutely no
no move yeah now I'm just I'm just
having everything here beef I this he is
tied down to the b5 verb porn and the
simple continuation would be like Quincy
three Quincy seven and and it's gone
okay yeah one problem is I can't just
take here no I cannot sorry hey if you
don't have oxy eight so this is this is
nonsense what I'm saying okay
it still looks weird t5 I can't take it
play c5 yeah maybe that's that's
actually had a good the good
continuation here yeah I would love any
five but I have gotten these got 95 and
I don't want to trade it and I'm just
playing rock c5 next and win the
beatport I think after way turn after
night after this year I can also think
about taking the pawn and then I really
have rook c8 at the end of it not clear
Roxy 5s maybe 96
might be five rupee fire Bishop b5 queen
bee five rook c8 check night we ate this
looks like really bad but am i winning
Queen to e5 maybe it's not only it's not
a winner amazingly enough okay and now
that I need to play that not not much
else it's okay i mean 96 I go Bishop b5
it does not have a way to save the b5
porn I believe yeah but should be five
now or am I somehow getting into into
some pinning business song mmhmm yeah
but hmm we should be I can just take on
these cigs next and everything's fine
rook be five rupee 594 Bishop Ruger be a
check is a very easy win and now after
basically any Queen move I'll take e6
and just try to win with the extra porn
yeah don't oh okay
okay I can still play 96 it's made on g7
this threat I wonder there's something
else maybe it's something even stronger
come on keep it simpler that's really
one of the most important rules and
chest it done it applies to all kinds of
things but it also applies to chairs if
you have a simple-looking solution or a
complicated one take the simple 10 came
for this this is not helping him I
understand you want some activity with
Queenie five Queenie five threatening
Brooksie seven or or should I play and
Bishop c4 even yeah Bishop c4 is also
quite good yeah yeah get the get the
bishop exchanged here Bishop g2 Bishop a
successor is disastrous
here the extra porn is so nice and all
but the problem is also is very very
very wiki king and it looks like i'll
maybe get on the seventh of the rook or
something this is so probably and not a
position that black and save
probably need to take on c4 or rook the
eighth is this this type of moose rock
to rock too eh okay I guess this should
be should be good Jam Roxy seven
threatened Bishop g5 threatened rookie
file threatened mmm it's quite quite a
lot of threats
okay there is no move really ok rock t5
takes Bishop takes yeah yeah too many
threats really i think it remember i'm
not not one hundred percent sure would
think you played a quite a number of
second-tier moves and it all summed up
to to disaster at the end check king of
a droop tweenage land may resign this is
checkmate one way to do it um i think it
was it was probably okay up to up to
somewhere up to here i mean i don't
think black is in that terrible shape
okay maybe because i play a wrong 'if
I've go computer gives me a big
advantage you'll be five it does not
like that that that does not surprise me
but I'm still curious 'if I've is the
movement okay I don't understand it at
all takes our bishop techniques okay I
exam as usual its tactics the a5 porn
it's not so easy to keep the a5 porn now
I understand so I'm just attacking the
rook and something like that one just
check just take that
that's tricky so black cannot take on
lehigh for okay when if you don't know
if you cannot take their then you have a
problem yeah okay this move I didn't
consider at all played this one and now
computer wants to take on before with
only a slight edge to white yeah this is
a bit what I thought yeah okay it is
it's just not very comfortable to have
to potentially recons the set of one and
around here it gets it gets it gets
uncomfortable yeah and this is I think
losing yeah I computer confirms that it
must a blast you must play Bishop c4
yeah I mean good or worse a good or bad
you must do that and something like that
and then I wanted to to get the night
over to c3 like that maybe yeah I can do
it okay I can do that I was briefly
thinking that the night might come here
but this is knight on d5 is much much
much more problem for black yeah this
this type of structure is just very nice
i have this safely blockaded the night
is always attacking here just going
there that's very nice for white but
it's still a position that black can try
to defend and t it's probably just gone
this has not helped so much okay well
I've got I've got a very nice position
here but it's not like I'm winning and I
think here I'm winning because it drops
material already yeah Bobby should be
six but it's not much of a big deal i
can also i I didn't even consider that
white I can take a form but this is just
um
I think simple and simple and good yeah
yeah as I suspected he made a number of
second-rate moves which led to led to
the problems here you five I don't I
don't know i mean probably you can just
take and play play this type of position
white is a bit better because of the
porn but it seems more more more tough
more tough defense than what he played
ok thanks for watching